[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing a topic
that was heavily requested by you guys
how do the headmasters portraits at
hogwarts work
specifically we'll be taking a look at
how exactly these paintings are able to
give advice
since the people portrayed in them are
dead
and whether or not a subject's abilities
while alive impacts how intelligent
their portrait is in death
first off it's important to note before
we get going on the actual portraits
that these paintings are entirely
different from the magical photographs
that appear throughout the harry potter
series as you've likely noticed in the
novels and films
unlike the hogwarts portraits
photographs in the wizarding world can
be of witches and wizards who are either
dead or alive
it does not matter they are also unable
to speak to the living
they simply move in a sort of loop
waving or smiling at the person who took
the picture
as we see harry's parents do in a few
pictures of them that he finds
so while yes wizarding world photographs
are technically enchanted they're not
nearly as interactive as the painted
portraits you'll find at hogwarts and
other important establishments here's
why the portraits at hogwarts are
painted by witch or wizard artists who
have used enchantments in their paint to
enable their subjects to be able to move
and interact with the living
photographs on the other hand capture a
moment in time and are then typically
developed with magic in order to give
them their moving quality
what's more the outcome of magical
pictures seems to depend entirely on who
develops it and what the photograph will
be used for for example in the chamber
of secrets colin krievie's pictures
which he magically enhances by
developing them in a potion
greatly differs from the images on the
chocolate frog cards
which by the way seem to be the least
sentient of all the magical images that
were introduced to in the wizarding
world at least in my opinion
in fact if i'm being completely honest
all magical pictures in harry potter
kind of remind me of the live photos
that us muggles can take on any iphone
but i digress
back to the hogwarts portraits
these are paintings that hang throughout
hogwarts castle
all enchanted by the artists who painted
them
it's important to note though that most
of the portraits hanging around the
school are what jk rowling has referred
to as two-dimensional
yes they can interact with the living
but only in a very limited way
here's what they can do they can move
from frame to frame even frames that
belong to another subject
although they seem to be constrained to
the frames that are hung within the
school meaning i do not believe that
these figures can leave hogwarts
they can also grant access to secret
passageways and have extremely surface
level conversations
these interactions provide them with the
opportunity to make use of the phrases
and mannerisms that they were known for
while alive however they cannot offer
quality advice or contribute to in-depth
conversations
for example you may recall the portrait
of the fat lady
she is of course the memorable figure
who guards the entrance to the
gryffindor common room
now she has the ability to remember
secret passcodes and admit students to
the room based on a correct response
or deny them access based on an
incorrect one she can even engage in
like conversation offering the odd
remark to students whether they ask for
it or not but she absolutely cannot
provide highly intelligent discourse or
advice
if harry or another student had asked
for her opinion on say where voldemort
had hidden his horcruxes i'd wager that
she would have looked at them blankly
and regurgitated one of her standard
phrases
this of course is substantially
different from the portraits of the
hogwarts head masters
which by all accounts are quite a bit
more intelligible than all that
while i've heard the theory that the
sentience of a portrait subject may have
depended on the skill of the witch or
wizard who painted the head teacher
according to jk rowling that is simply
not true
what it does depend on though is the
power and abilities of the witch or
wizard who is featured in the painting
yes that's right
it is indeed true that the more powerful
wizard was in life the more life-like
their portrait stands to be
this does a great deal to explain why
dumbledore's headmaster portrait is so
capable of in-depth conversation
advising severus from his frame well
after his death
after all he was one of the most
powerful wizards to have ever lived
but how exactly does this work
well as it turns out it also takes a bit
of effort from the subject prior to
their demise as it is tradition for
important witches and wizards to sit for
portraits while still alive
so that they may continue to pass down
their knowledge after death paintings
were completed well before most head
teachers passed on
their portraits were privately kept
hidden away so that they would only
interact with their living counterparts
subjects would then visit their
paintings as often as possible
imparting memories and wisdom onto them
basically teaching the paintings how to
be them
for this reason you can see how a
portrait would be able to gain so much
insight into how to represent a subject
but be limited in a way that say a ghost
would not be
that is a portrait is only able to grow
and learn from their subject through
their visits while they are still alive
they can become very good
representations of a witch or wizard
however they cannot grow or learn from
future interactions or events in the
same way a ghost could
rather the head teacher portraits are
more like a sentient memoir of each
professor
able to respond and provide advice to
people
based on the memories and wisdom told to
them before the real witch or wizard
died in any case this all explains how
albus was able to assist snape so well
since dumbledore knew that he was dying
and that their plan was to have severus
succeed him as headmaster
he likely would have taken much care to
share with his portraits all the details
and theories he had about voldemort the
horcruxes and harry's part in it all
so that the painted version of himself
could support snape after he was gone
another thing to note is that each witch
or wizard is only painted once
from there they may have various frames
hung in different establishments that
want to honour them and the subjects are
able to travel from frame to frame at
will we see this take place at different
times in the series for example
dumbledore sends the professor everard
from his frame at hogwarts to his frame
at the british ministry of magic
headquarters at one point
and we know that phineas nigella's black
can go back and forth between his
hogwarts portrait and his frame at the
ancestral home of the black family at 12
grimmeld place
which actually brings up another point
despite differing views and opinions
each head teacher portrait is bound to
serve the current headmaster or
headmistress
to be honest i'm not entirely sure how
this works if the subject has multiple
frames hung in different places from
what i know the subjects seem to only be
bound to hogwarts in this way
what i mean is that i don't believe that
a portrait in the ministry of magic is
obligated to serve the current minister
for magic or anything an interesting
anomaly for the school if you ask me the
final comment i'll make on this topic is
regarding the dark lord if someone who
has a portrait magically painted of
themselves can spread their views and
advice for all eternity
why wouldn't a wizard like voldemort or
even grindelwald for that matter
have their likeness made into one of
these magical portraits of course for
the regular witch or wizard i imagine it
would be difficult to find an artist
willing to do their portraits i'd also
wager it'd be quite expensive
however for voldemort and grindelwald
surely it wouldn't have been too hard to
find an artist willing to paint them i
mean there had to be some artists among
the death eaters and acolytes right
well for one i think both of these dark
wizards were entirely too busy pursuing
other forms of
what they would have considered more
potent powerful and potentially
everlasting forms of magic such as
horcruxes
the second reason is that i think these
wizards were too vain to plan for after
their deaths so consumed were they by
subjugating those who opposed them
during their lifetime that they weren't
even willing to consider
what would come after they died and with
that we have come to the end of another
video
what did you think do you agree with my
theories
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below
and as always if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
the channel
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]